96 year old Dick Van Dyke paying it
forward literally to those in need
I was very generous of you had you had
cash for the holidays
the Hollywood icon who turns 97 in
December was super humble and generous
handing out five dollar bills and
chatting with people looking for work in
Malibu better I have some fires that
come by one worker at the community
labor exchange described the legendary
actor in three words
there you go he always is and always
will be dick first started coming to the
nonprofit Center to give money away last
year during the tough times of the
pandemic and how cool is this in may he
was out wearing a sweatshirt at the red
just a spoonful of sugar
if sugar helps the medicine go down dick
starred in the 1964 musical Mary Poppins
alongside Julie Andrews one of his last
roles was in the film sequel with Emily
Blunt it's always
super you must choose to be a trooper
look at you what's the secret what are
you drinking what are you eating what
are you doing because we all want to do
whatever you're doing that's funny I
I've always kept moving which is the
most important thing I'm either singing
or dancing or something dick told
Michelle he starts every morning dancing
with his wife Arlene silver who's 45
years younger there's is an art to just
making people smile and happy yeah just
happens that everything I got to do has
been something light and helped somebody
lighten the day and it feels so good it
feels so good it wasn't a mission but to
have done that for people just makes me
feel great
[Music]